this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes t.c
Columbia edu it likes to walk around and
I usually don't use a mic very well so
I'm going to try my best to stay in my
box here but I may move to the side and
I'm so glad and took it but see so many
young people here because this is going
to be a very very informative
presentation and panel presentation and
I'm going to kind of health advocate for
aural health awareness and a health
educator I am also part of the health
disparities program of dr. Wallace's
program and thank you everybody for
coming in to learn a little bit
information about oral health and oral
health disparities before I start just
to kind of get you guys going here and
you're wondering what does all have to
do have to do with anything so here's
why this is a very important area of
health care
okay if you have had at least one cavity
in your mouth please end up
okay all right I won't even ask about
gum disease cuz we have enough people
standing and the point I want to make
with this is that if you look around the
room almost the entire room is standing
at the exception of maybe one or two
people one or two or three people and
are those people that are still sitting
they either don't know they have a
cavity or they have to go to the dentist
so most of everybody in the United
States has been affected with at least
one Kevin sit down and the point I want
to make about that is that just that you
just saw in this room and I could go
through to increase impatient any
seminar any place any school any
Community Health Program anywhere in the
United States and have everyone do that
I'm going to get different reactions and
different people standing in different
areas and the point that I want to make
with that is that oral health disease is
the silent epidemic it is one of the few
diseases that affect almost the entire
population and at the same time it's one
of the ones that is usually not included
and most of your health reforms your
health agendas your health policies the
summit that they had last week was
President Barack Obama of the hundred
health professionals that were there and
guaranteed if there was at least one
dental professional in the room it was
probably just one and so oral health is
a very immediate
awareness point that everyone needs to
rub to be taught about it a lot of time
you say I want to know about cavities I
know about disease well that's the
assumption that's one of the barriers so
if you can just bear with me for a few
minutes we're going to go through a
crash course in dentistry 101 because I
don't want to assume that anybody does
or does not know what a cavity is or
what gum disease is because all of this
is essential on how it's related to your
whole body's well-being okay and so the
first part was introduction which I
wasn't going to bore you guys by reading
all of that so when our health
disparities first before we go into the
or health conditions health disparities
are differences in the incidence
prevalence mortality burden of disease
and other add personal conditions or
outcomes that exist among specific
population groups in the United States
and if you take this same definition and
you just insert the word or health
disparities it has the same implications
the only thing that is mainly different
is that oral health is dependent on your
oral health status and all health status
is defined by the presence of current
dental disease conditions so just to
talk about a few of them dental disease
conditions like we said I just had you
guys stand up about tooth decay and
we're gonna go for it for a second some
people call it dental caries so what is
tooth decay and see us it's interactive
I don't like to sit in the lecture to
people so I'd like to have what I call a
town hall panel presentation was very
interactive which really helps with the
understanding of everything and since I
have some very bright young people in
the room does anyone want to stand up
and tell me what they think a cavity or
tooth decay is
not to put anybody on the spot
and you're forgetting everybody
everybody's a love shot that's fun I can
take with a tooth decay is no call the
tears okay well we gotta go on cuz I
gotta get through this yeah
that is very good there whatever she
said that is very good that is you just
saw my whole definition problem right
there and that is basically what it is
the folks who are older are receiving
people a little more scientific
explanation is basically what she said
but tooth decay is basically active
disease process which is the destructive
process of tooth structure whether it be
the outside of the tooth which is these
enamel going into the inside or in the
root surfaces and basically you have to
have three things in order for Cabot's
to occur of course you have to have a
tooth the second thing is you have to
have food and the last thing is bacteria
so when we speak of the bacteria there
are normally two different types of
bacteria responsible and that is
actually called streptococcus mutants
and oneness now we're both of those what
happens is the bacteria and I know we
all think that our mouths are very clean
places but your mouth is wanted the
nastiest places in your whole body okay
there are over 500 bacteria in your
mouth
some of them are what we call good
bacteria because there's a bacteria the
thing is when this bacteria we're just
transmitted through your saliva it
attaches to a little sticky pellicle on
the teeth called plaque and when this
bacteria in this plaque gets on the
teeth now you start to eat and you start
to digest carbohydrates and the
carbohydrates are broken down into sugar
and it produces an acid called lactic
acid so when this assets to the teeth
and it starts to corrode the teeth teeth
are in the state of demineralization of
remineralisation for a period of time so
sometimes you can go to a dentist and
dentists may say you just have a little
bitty small cavity so I just want to
kind of watch it that means that
is still able to remineralize itself the
pH in your mouth which is a very acidic
place if that pH gets below five point
five then the to stability to repair
itself is not going to happen anymore
that cavity ends up getting deeper
deeper until you end up having pain you
end up either losing the tooth have an
half something called a root canal and
worst case scenario if the tooth ends up
performing an infection and you get an
abscess and the abscess goes untreated
you can't it can't result in death so
there's nothing cavities are not just
this young lady was correct they do
start off just as holes but they can
progress on into something more serious
and I'll give you some examples of that
a little bit later there okay and just
two cavities can I know this incise I'm
glad my young people here could not he
is I mean you know these are examples of
cavities here and they can come in all
forms they can come in big holes in the
teeth but they can come on the side of
the teeth
the reason x-rays are important is
because sometimes the case starts in
between the teeth where if you don't
have proper oral hygiene and you're not
flossing we as dennis can't see it just
clinically looking in your mouth we have
to take x-rays to see how it starts in
between okay now let's move on go
quicker on this crash course here okay
paradigm disease no one put anybody else
on the slide but periodontal disease and
it is an infection that is of your gods
and of your of your bone that's the area
that holds the teeth in there your
surroundings tooth structure supporting
structures that hold the teeth in there
and periodontal disease can come in two
major categories it normally starts off
as gingivitis and gingivitis is
basically when your gums get real puffy
red and bleed very easily reason is
doing that is because of that plaque
that's embedded up underneath the gums
as gingivitis progresses on it ends up
turning into
the limousines and their different
stages of periodontal disease so this is
a very important part to because
periodontal disease a lot of times what
young people am adults don't understand
is that basically when your gum tissue
attaches to the tooth
it makes what's called a pocket and is
basically scientific name is a solace
when that plaque gets you not underneath
the gum tissues with the bacteria
embedded in there the gum tissues were
starting to cool down and so you're
you're actually start seeing the roots
of the teeth that it teary eights on
until the teeth eventually get loose and
they even have to come out before they
fall out so para Don disease is
something that we definitely need to get
a control on and we'll see later how
periodontal disease and it's bacteria
I'm talking about has a lot more total
body effects where it can affect other
systemic things in your body and this is
basically what I understand I just like
to kind of explain it like that where
you have a little pocket and if you take
your pocket I had a pocket and you stick
stuff down in there that Plagueis this
stuff is going down in there so that
pocket gets full so you've got to take
all that stuff out of the pocket in
order to get those gums to tighten back
up and where you have you never can get
rid of unfortunately you never can get
rid of all the bacteria in your mouth
but you do want to keep it under control
to keep you from having these problems
here okay all pathology just some of the
things we want to mention I'll start
with the Aptus ulcers those are the
things where you get those little areas
in your mouth and look like little
blisters it's two different types of
blisters now one is an actus ulcer and
then the other one is what we call a
herpetic lesion or some people call it
herpes okay and some people like to call
them cold sores that's the nice name for
it okay but basically you can occur
anywhere in your mouth your tongue your
roof of your mouth your cheeks your your
gum tissue and on the outside of your
lips there so that's what the herpetic
lesion and then apis also is usually
only a curl on the inside or cancer
basically occurs in occur in the same
areas your
your cheeks your lips your tongue the
most common place for oral cancer is on
the lateral border of the tongue like if
you lift your tongue up and in dental
offices now pretty much this standard is
to do what we call a or cancer screening
so if you go to your dentist's office
and they're not doing the or cancer
screening you need if you're if they're
not saying lift your tongue up to the
roof your mouth stick your tongue out
you need to say Doug did you do it or
cancer screening because this is
critical and before I go on to the
prevention I'm gonna give you guys just
a example of oral cancer and I'll talk
about the burdens of all of these
diseases in a minute but just to speak
on or cancer to show you how devastating
it can be you can have or count so that
starts in the mouth originate it and
some of the predisposing factors to that
can be cigarette smoking chewing tobacco
overconsumption of alcohol those are all
things that can increase the chances of
oral cancer you can also have or cancer
that originated somewhere else in your
body and that has metastasized to the
mouth for example you can have lung
cancer you can have breast cancer you
can have all kind of cancers those are
the two most common ones that end up
going through your bloodstream and into
your your lymph vessels and they can end
up showing in your mouth
and so as Dennis when we're doing that
oral cancer screening and we can see
different lesions we have to do a a
biopsy on and I have actually had three
cases in the last six months where I've
diagnosed and had to send them for a
biopsy of cancer one was a metastatic
lung cancer patient came in and I just
knew something was wrong with them he
looked you know weight loss all of those
Jepson sissonne to go to his medical
doctor he said he had gone to his
medical doctor I called the medical
doctor medical doctor said nothing was
wrong and I was just very adamant that
he go back and I ended up actually just
taking him to the emergency room myself
because that's how nervous I was for
this gentleman turnout he was in state
four of lung cancer and needless to say
four months later this gentleman was
gone and one thing and I'm kind of
skipping around because I'm going to
talk about collaboration of health care
providers a little bit later because if
I call the medical doctor and I'm trying
we're trying to treat this patient
together
I really we really need to talk about
the patient's total health and if I'm on
the phone and the doctors you know any
hey young he's fine get it off and I'm
telling you no something is wrong then I
need a little bit more collaboration
because I'm telling you something's
wrong with this man they get not taking
a chest x-ray they had not done any of
these things and the gentleman had a 13
centimeter lesion on his lungs that
would have been caught years ago so that
that pretty much devastated me and that
was like I said that was last year and I
had just gotten into health disparities
probably the year before and when that
happened then I really just made it my
job to go out and explain to people all
over from students to adults to
politicians to everybody or health
awareness because it's just not
something that oh good so I don't get
this tooth taken out it's just not like
that anymore there are too many
total-body connections with that okay
but yeah not to eat you guys all yeah
but I just had to give you that example
because you know it's very very
important some of the things that we can
do to present to prevent a lot of these
diseases and things that I'm talking
about is things that you know I'm
preaching to the choir you guys know
brushing and flossing and then go to the
dentist on a regular visit but would you
believe that I would say 80% of my
patients that come in and I don't care
if they are 82 or two in their 5x10 mow
you brush yeah brush doc I'd brush twice
a day you know and I'm seeing plaque and
it's harder everywhere in the mouth and
I'm like you brush tries it again and
you would not believe how
any educated people and we're gonna talk
about stereotyping but you know it's
just like you would think that you can't
assume that everybody knows just the
basics because most of them were not
brushing the right way they were
brushing two and three or four times
away a day but they weren't brush it in
the right way so unfortunately all these
things fall under education literacy so
that's why I want to kind of give you a
little rash course of course we have
dietary modification you guys probably
saw the news where the Appalachian
Mountain kids did you all see that
dr. Manor and the kids were pretty much
drinking Mountain Dew for breakfast
lunch and dinner okay well they're
pretty mountains all over that was their
their device mountain dew in Georgia
sweet tea sweet tea and kool-aid you
know so everywhere has their Appalachian
Mountains that's what I like to call it
but actually the dietary control
controlling the sugar intake because
remember I said you have to have those
three ingredients the tooth food and the
bacteria and not just any food it has to
be food as carbohydrates where you've
broken down into those sugars so if you
decrease your sugar intake and of course
decrease the bacterial count in your
mouth then the likelihood you're gonna
be like the young lady that didn't stand
up you won't have any cavities in there
and with since the nineteen seventies
dentistry has come a long way with
prevention and we have seen a decrease
in the number of or disease like tooth
decay but unfortunately certain
population groups are still in left
behind and a lot of these changes that
have come where we've seen improvements
is due to things like dental sealants
and basically dental sealants is like a
little protective coating that go on
your permanent molar teeth for young
people to keep them from getting
cavities later but older people it's a
little too late for the dental sealants
but we like to try to catch the young
people early with it it's the sealant so
they don't have to go through what we
went through
of course fluoride
fluoridation has been a godsend because
unfortunately it's not in every
community which is part of what we have
disparities but water fluoridation is
one of the reasons we have decreased
decay since the 70s and of course
fluoride fluoride varnishes fluoride
toothpastes all those things like that
so moving forward real quick here if we
talk about oral health disparities
there's two groups I want to talk about
as far as adults well let's just start
with the kids well look for my building
here there are certain population groups
that increase risk for tooth decay for
kids and they are as follows the
following infants and children are at
risk for a tooth for tooth decay empathy
and children living in communities
without fluoridated water which is what
I said infants and children from
families with low incomes infants and
children from some racial and ethnic
minority groups infants and children
with limited or no dental insurance
infants and children whose parents have
less than a high school education
infants and children with special health
care needs for example those who have
developmental disabilities like Down
syndrome or cleft lip and palate so
these are some of the health disparities
some of the burdens and some of the
reasons for the disparities with kids
okay
with adults and we're talking about
statistics as far as dental sealants
less than 40% of African American
children receive don't sealants as
compared to 60% of white children
usually receive dental sealants so the
reason that is is mailing do it's a
couple of different reasons of course
number one sealants are not free and so
when you go into the lobe you know two
different barriers like socioeconomic
status and things like that
and then of course since it's a
preventive mode you
think most dental insurances public but
we don't go over all that in just a
second - so after that in a little bit
more detail here african-american males
or of course have the highest incident
of remember the old cancer that I was
just talking about they have the highest
incidence of oil and pharyngeal cancer
and by the way United so just diagnosed
three cancers in the last six months all
three of those were african-american
males so and I have a diverse population
so I look fruits and screen everyone but
that's just to give you an example of
how prevalent that is with their of
course higher levels of gingivitis and
here alone disease we're seeing in
african-americans as reported to white
and of course that's the paradigm
disease that are coming about the
gingivitis and that's why I gave that
crash course because I didn't want to
assume anybody knew what I was talking
about when I say it periodontal disease
because some some people call it area
some people call it different things so
I wanted us to be on the same
terminology with that and like I said
african-american churches are 40 percent
less likely to have dental sealants
employed Hispanic males usually we
receive and this kind of confused me
with this statistic but I say employ
Hispanic males usually have less than
more care than white but I guess that's
significant because they're employed and
yet they still have less little care
then the majority population here okay
see so the disparities do exist even
though we have come a long way with with
our dentistry and improving the health
but like I said it's just certain
populations that are still being left
behind with that so if we talk about the
barriers now what I'd like to say is it
in my opinion what is the difference
between disparities with the rest of the
medical health its vs. or health the
biggest thing that I see is the biggest
barrier to access is what we just said
insurance coverage because most of your
population and a half some form of
medical coverage although you see the
statistics with that where a lot of the
population did not have medical
insurance as well but what dental
coverage just to give you an example and
some of you all in here may be awareness
for your particular jobs most of the
time if you have double coverage it
maxes out at a very low amount per year
okay and so of course my dentistry has
changed so much that is not just taking
out teeth you have to do these proxies
treatments and processes for to get rid
of the periodontal disease like deep
clean and scale and a root planing and
these procedures and unfortunately by
the time you get your deep cleaning done
your insurance is next out and you can't
get your your fillings done and so if
your I don't enough to have the general
insurance coverage is basically I don't
really even like to call it coverage and
the general coming out see we just call
it a extra benefit and for those who do
not have any dental coverage at all you
either have to resort to Medicaid and
Medicare Medicare doesn't cover
dentistry so Medicaid is a whole nother
governmental issue with that so if you
have Medicaid they're not paying for all
the treatment it was adults they're
paying to have your teeth taken out and
that's basically it there's one group
with adults that is covered a little bit
more and that's with that's with some
mothers and actually with prenatal
mothers and a reason being is because
the prenatal connection between mothers
and preterm babies and you guys have
probably heard the research
now what happens with that that's one of
the variants as well because when you're
trying to get access to care as a
preterm I mean as a expectant mother if
you do not get your teeth clean the
bacteria that's in your mouth they form
an ingredient that actually initiates
later and so that's why you're having a
preterm labor so there are a lot of
medical interactions cardiovascular
disease there's a hard connection with
the or health there is diabetes and
quite a few other things okay
lack of insurance coverage like I said
is one of the biggest things lack of
regular source of care most patients
that come in in certain areas and
in-stock certain population groups
they're fainting is they're coming in
for emergency care they don't come in
for routine care structural barriers
transportation compliance cultural
influence I think Shana get a cultural
competence partum or no knowing what a
culture wants some cultures that come in
Latin Hispanic cultures a lot of times
they're they may have cultural
differences where their their culture
may indicate that they are not wanting
to have a certain type of treatment
certain cultures are working Saturday's
there are certain cultures that have
certain really religion affiliations
where you know certain things can't be
done on Saturday so all of that falls
under culture countries where you have
to be aware of the patient's needs
educational health literacy how many
people know exactly what I just told you
guys about the decay and all of that
patient provider communication when
we're talking us providers to patients
sometimes all they hear is Charlie
Brown's mom and dad ball ball ball ball
ball and they turn right around
go ask the assistant somebody know what
what do they mean by that so we as
providers have to do a better job of
communicating with the patients and
scarcity of providers there's a 160,000
dentists in the United States right now
the projected census there is over three
billion three I think was 305 million
people and typically with a dentist
patient ratios there should only be
about 1500 patients per provider so
that's about 60 million people just get
left out not practice alone I'm seeing I
have about 4,000 patients though we're
you're over work in the students that
are coming here and we're not recruiting
people that look like us
so it works which it brings me to
another workforce diversity you know you
want to recruit all these do to save you
guys interested in yoga schools when I
get done come up and talk to me okay
cuz we like that diversity Indian like I
said I provided discrimination and dr.
Benton Court did an excellent job
talking about that yesterday when he was
talking about just not stereotype my
patients don't assume if a patient comes
in because they look a certain way or
you know that they're not going to want
this type of treatment plan or that
trying to treatment plan you got to act
like everybody is the same and never
assume Dennis Green is first visits all
of those are at barriers if you look at
the graph I mean the chart on the screen
or else ratings or not exams they're
like when we go to the schools or like
the band
they're two or three-minute looks to
identify disease but not diagnose okay
right now only 12 states have mandatory
laws of screenings and those are the
ones that are up there one of the things
that we need to do as a breakthrough is
mandate for states the duties or health
screens
okay and I'm almost done here
recruitment and retention like I said
more for diversity and workforce health
care providers from that rate more like
a gave you that example about the doctor
not calling me back
culture aversion just making sure you're
familiar with everyone else's culture
and some of the breakthroughs we've
achieved just came back from the
Leadership Summit with the office of
minority health some of the things that
are on the horizon number one you guys
probably know about the diamante driver
story with a little fella end up going
from abscess a brain abscess when it's
starting off and then infection in his
mouth
where you needed a tooth pool he didn't
get the treatment she called five or six
different dental offices nobody this
Tamara would see him and he was the same
in end up costing us out of tax money
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in emergency room fees for where they
were trying to treat him and he still
end up passing and so we're trying to do
like a centralized location where if
you're in anywhere in the United States
you can go to a website and it can tell
you all of the free clinics all of the
free clinics in an area okay and
basically that's gonna help where nobody
has to call up and say where do I go to
get some additional services or free
services so that's one of the things
that we
trying to form a partnership with a
whole bunch of different organizations
to bring about more health awareness to
so my time man is yoga about three four
five parts so I guess time to yeah okay
opening so I'm sure you guys probably
wouldn't have a lot of questions and
things like that but in conclusion is
just a whole bunch of things we need to
do and the main point of my being here
and I went to different conferences and
speaking I just don't want or health to
be left out okay I just if you just I
mean cuz time was short I couldn't even
go through half the things both you know
medical and how is related all of these
things I gave you a couple examples just
to show you important so I don't know
what capacity everybody is in but you
know you just need to spread word
because it needs to be included and
there are a lot of different things we
can do to help decrease disparities and
like I said one of them is we've got to
get more funding for dental care that
universal health care about that
stimulus package is to include some oral
health funding as well okay so thank you
very much for your time
yes well they're intermix now actually
we just had that meeting last week and
it's quite a few organizations is a
partnership like sentence apartment
Health and Human Services the CDC the
NIH is like the HAMP this particular
meeting it was like the heads of every
organization and the devil school
director who was you know the director
of a American dental school education
that one is responsible is yellow school
because they're they're trying to make
sure that you put it in the curriculums
now about the cultural competence for
the students as well but their random
process of trying to do that website but
of course and that's the whole thing you
might dr. Wallace was talking about
action you know and we get so many Mel
adeptly responses and gives you like all
the dog by the time this happen on being
in law so it's all about time to seven
don't want anybody to think like that
we're trying to get on it but we have to
move through those stages of change and
move from everybody knows all the
statistics everybody knows what we need
to do is just as sometimes got to move
on you know got to put the action in
plan
so not just Saturday but I would say you
know at least in the next few months you
know time is critical we can't have
another diamantes Robin you know so time
is critical for that
yes
how do your question okay
there is a reason why you're going so
darker
be proud of a system okay
it is the Pinkman just like you have
pigment in your skin okay now that's the
kind of dark darkness I'm talking about
there if you're talking about like a
dark brown or dark black that statement
just like you have in the rest of your
body if it's like red or blue the next
that picture I showed up there gum
disease then that's something else but
if it's just brown and you notice it
gets a little bit more as you get age
it's just like if you get darker areas
anywhere else on your body and I went to
dental school and a majority school and
went to the University of Iowa and I
finished at Emory and I'll tell you
there is 2% African American there and
most of my colleagues my dental students
would you believe my colleagues my
classmates except say makes that
question because they had never seen
before so that's very very good as far
as the oral cancer did you pass it on to
your partner or your kids
oh you guys are asking some very good
questions here okay remember I talked
about different types of or cancers the
ones that are originating from the mouth
those are usually not transmitted okay
you know there's one that I didn't
mention it because we have a right over
time but there is a new cancer but it's
not new it's been researched for a while
and it's free at Powerbars call
HPV you know that is it's not the human
papillomavirus okay
and normally you know that causes
cervical cancer okay for females okay
because their best they're ever going to
be like with cervical cancer so I'm
keeping it you know straight because I
know you're okay chuckles I'm here but
if you just you guys are open up and
you're smart enough if you think about
how cervical cancer can spread to the or
cabin okay all right so that's another
that's a whole another presentation that
I have given before as well
protect protect to correct it is right
it was a viral infection if you attack a
lot of Roma is a virus and it is spread
and that's the care so that you can
spread off the herpes and all of that
that can be transmitted for part in
department and you know what a lot of
times it is not you know in the normal
transmission ways if I grab her pin and
let's say your school and your got your
candy mouth because this isn't intending
to this presenter just presenting so
hard up here and you gotta peel solar
something in your mouth and now your
girlfriend on the side as you can I
borrow you counsel and now she's got it
and now she's using it and some reason
she gets disorient and now she sticks it
in her mouth as well viruses can lay
opening hard surface for over 24 to 48
hours depend on different viruses so you
have to be careful when you're sharing
even like I said a pill so drink
your dream you know look you know you
just have to be careful with it soon and
like I said well it's not transmitted
like oh my god and it's the hardest
thing with parents bringing kids into my
office and you know I'd like to tell
them you know a child has herpes are
perfectly
they're lucky like what yeah exactly
like kind of how did she get it you know
and so not only are we or health care
providers we have the counselors we have
to be preachers you know a little bit of
everything you know and you have to calm
them down so I thought but the child but
not gonna take 45 minutes calming the
mom down because she's ready to go home
sick Susan may they as soon as you may
have been doing something she's not
supposed to be doing but you know how to
explain what it is not only transmitted
in that
are you inclu your own even in Georgia
I'm in Georgia Atlanta Georgia yes so
you can come down because the times are
changing now that is becoming more and
more frequent of popular amongst young
crowds is there a way for you to get
oral cancer with oral piercings right
now there has not been research to short
a great connection with the oral
piercings you know usually when patients
come in with the tongs peers and things
like that to be honest with you I really
just don't like it I really don't like
it because I really see you know
bacteria just like I'm talking about the
bacteria to select and therefore that's
just one more item in your mouth they
can collect bacteria around it you know
and so and you know the young people the
young people that come in with it
they've had these uh tongue piercing in
some panty in two years and never taken
those mr. LaBrie now and I'm like take
that thing out now some of the company
in appearance don't even know they miss
you know so if you right now there's no
links between you or cancer there's a
whole bunch of other stuff not good
stuff that can happen from tongue
piercings well like I said you can get
bacterial infections
um which ends up where if you get an
infection you can notice even pus coming
from the area you know
and like I said you know what halitosis
but you can get that anywhere but you
know more halitosis is this it is all
because of the bacteria that's
collecting around there so that's one of
the main things you know if you if it's
not in there correctly you risk the
chance of aspiration announcer question
in case some of these students want to
become a dentist
can you tell them some of the classes or
the type of classes they should take in
Middle School in high school what they
should study and think about the college
their health excellent excellent
well of course you know what I'm going
to say science science science and you
know what you're in middle school and
high school where you're thinking what
am I taking this now plans I don't want
to do anything with math I thought the
same thing
and you just don't believe how many
numbers you have to work with in
dentistry when you're trying to give
someone an aesthetic and they say is 1.8
cc's and you're trying to do that toxic
kilograms of body weight of the child
you have to really be able to add all
those things up and you got to think
quick so it's not like you have four for
tests and forget it it's tough it has to
stay up there so take if you're
interested in any health care field you
know take as much funny it's as you
click can take your math and not just
find some now
because you know what you're looking for
well-rounded students now take your
social studies take your electives all
that because all of that believe in a
man like I exist saying I mean you're
not yet just going to be a doctor and
healthcare provider you're all kinds of
training is going to come up so you know
take as many science and math courses
but be sure to stay well rounded and you
know a lot of times with dental schools
and medical schools they're not just
looking for 4.0 GPA they're looking to
see that you participated in a trip like
this you know and it's competitive you
know it is competitive so you have to
make sure you just do a whole bunch of
things so you'll stand out more so than
everybody else okay any more questions
okay okay okay thank you all very very
much in I hope it was informative and I
hope you have a little bit more
appreciation to where it is a war help
thank you the preceding program was
brought to you by Teachers College
Columbia University please visit us
online at iTunes tC Columbia edu